hey this is Stevie TV just got back from
seeing spider-man homecoming and oh my
god was it spectacular literally
flawless across the board I don't say
there are many movies people know I'm
strict critics with movies and TV
nowadays but this blew me away this is
my favorite spider-man ever made Tom
Holland is my favorite spider-man and I
had a good feeling about this movie
after seeing Civil War because just from
the little glimpse of God of Tom Holland
I was like oh my god this is the
spider-man from the 90s cartoon I grew
up with some love plays it's a younger
spider-man he's the kid and this movie
really nailed that feel it males the
feel of him in high school with his
great goofy friend Ned and then the love
interest Liz is great because it's
different all that feels different and
then Michelle the freaky stalkerish girl
that has a crush on him is excellent
very funny a lot of humor here and I
really liked that whole field - feeling
like a kid in high school again watching
this movie and being a superhero from
high school it's such a cool connection
in a fresh feel which the other two
spider-man's I feel like never nailed at
all they could not get that they both
were too old looking this was perfect
spider-man I also love that Iron Man
took a step back in this I was afraid he
was going to take too much screen time
but he didn't he was a right amount he
was a side character for sure he was
spider-man's like dad figure but he
never stole a scene he never took
spider-man's movie
he's just a mentor I thought he was in
it perfectly which was key to this movie
being good and that and taken very
seriously I love animal birds one of my
favorite comedians as a gym teacher
showing the Captain America videos that
was great that's just some of the great
humorous parts another great humorous
scene to me is when spider-man is trying
to find work as spider-man he's not
getting it so he's like giving people
directions on the side of the road he's
given that all the directions I just
started howling in the earth oh that was
brilliant
yeah and I thought Jon Favreau the
director of Iron Man was great as the
babysitter for spider-man and Tony
Stark's like sidekick there
and he had some great humor too like
when you know when the vulture was
sending out that drone and to like
basically deter GPS and it shows jon
favreau like okay there's the location
cool like that kind of humor was so
spot-on and then the elevator scene was
one of the best scenes in the movie when
it's in DC and spider-man comes if you
saw that in imax like I did and 3d it
works amazing I was terrified to the
heights I'm someone was afraid of
heights so I felt like I was spider-man
that moment being freaked out it was
shot so beautifully and again great
humor the woman's like okay the safety
system is working the elevator and then
sobriety rents oops like the safety
systems not working and then again with
this suit with spider-man which was
awesome with when he's laying there and
she's giving him vice with the females
it was like that movie her it was great
and I loved the suit going into advanced
mode and showing all these little tech
like little gadgets and stuff and
versions of the web slinging that Tony
Stark put in the suit which gives
spider-man another fresh feel and it
just opens a door to all possibilities
here for future Spider movies which was
great and got a little tease all the
stuff he can do now so that definitely
needed that for spider-man to feel
unique still and exciting and it was so
cool at the end that suit that Tony
Stark has ready for spider-man whenever
he feels like joining the Avengers but
we'll get to that to it another time but
that suit looked awesome
I thought Michael Keaton killed is the
vulture he was the perfect casting for
it how about that shocking scene where
we find out he's Liz's father the whole
theater like gasps when that happened
like I did not see that coming they
pulled a fast one there it was such
great tension seeing Peter Parker with
the vulture in the kitchen with Liz on
prom night and there he's driving them
and that seemingly Keys and Tom Holland
in the car was spectacular it was so
good so well done and it really just
kept this movie constant there's no one
boring scene in this movie like the
whole movie was excellent and the boat
scene also amazing that scene the action
with the web slinging in the flipping
was so great
and it was great that Ironman came in
there to help out and kind of get
spider-man humbled a bit takes the suit
away and yeah I mean that was that was
so well shot and I love this movie was
being someone who lives in New York I
love the city scenes they had the sunset
it was so it looked amazing and how
about Marissa Tomei again again May
hysterical she's a hot aunt now and I
love her the movie ended with the what
the [ __ ] with her finding out that he is
spider-man Peter Parker such a great
ending and it was great cutscene with
Michael mando who we know from better
call Saul I review that show as well by
the way
but Michael mando is going to be
scorpion which is a nice cheese and he's
a great actor so I got me pumped then
the cut scene after obviously it was
like a Rick role with Captain America
that one stung a bit I wasn't crazy
about that I know they're making a joke
but recently the Marvel cutscenes have
been in but overall this movie was
excellent it had everything heart a love
story
humor action and it was just great
writing and great acting all around it
was so well cast and I love that he
didn't end up with Liz and that he
actually is hinting that towards
Michelle MJ take that as you want but
that maybe this time they're actually
not having the cute girl yet the
superhero now it's more like you know
the kind of freakish stockers girl she's
cute but it's different and that's I
like that I like that they went with
that because everything here felt fresh
and they kept it across the board
nothing felt recycled or reused even
though this is another spider-man reboot
it felt like a new spider movie I forgot
about the other spider movies so we'll
see what happens with what comes next
with spider-man but this was spectacular
I am giving this movie at 10 I never do
this one giving you the 10 because I had
such high expectations and they were all
met and it went even over that and I was
smiling coming out of theater it's been
so long since I've been to a movie in
movies I'm smiling I was happy I felt
like that flew by and again I really am
in a credible source or the Tom Holland
because he nailed it he nailed it he
nailed it he nailed it when he
is screaming under that rock when he's
just looking innocently excited he has
it down to a tee the perfect cast that
spider-man shows you if your lead actor
is the exact match you are going to soar
so props to that of course props to
Robert Downey jr. as always and everyone
in the cast great movie go see it I'm
going to see it again seen an IMAX 3d
it's totally worth it and please
subscribe comment below with your
thoughts of the movie I respond to
everybody let's get the discussion going
it agrees me disagree with me let me
have it tell me anything you caught
maybe about Ned leaves as well is he
going to be the Hobgoblin and he not is
MJ the same MJ we know and love so let's
see so comment below with your thoughts
and theories follow me asking the TV
show on Twitter Instagram and ask if
you've already won my main account and
please please subscribe keep coming back
that you show movies trailer reactions
you name it and it's all real no hacky
stuff no fake stuff these are my
opinions yes so keep coming back